[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Merry Christmas America
open phones number one bestselling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
Ramsey personality Ken Coleman is my
co-host today so if you want to talk
about jobs and work as you head into the
new year this is good day to do it Mr
Ken's here and he's the expert on that
I've always got an opinion and I'm an
expert on my opinion so uh you guys jump
in at any point we'll help you the phone
number is
5225 But Ken uh instead of going
straight into the phones which we
typically do I'm going to take a pause
here and say Yes congratulations to the
booth dudes yeah that's right James
Childs our fearless captain in there our
fearless producer James Childs and
Austin Ben uh they just Andrew they all
do a great job um making sure that we
are doing what we're supposed to do on
the this end of the microphones and um
for several I don't know years I guess
we have hovered in apple podcasts around
number 10 number 15 sometimes number
eight in the World on the main list of
all Apple podcasts um but today we had a
milestone we've never done this before
they they refreshed that list I think
about every 20 seconds so I don't know
how quickly it'll be there uh and won't
be there but uh as of a few moments ago
we're the number one podcast in the
world on Apple to go and uh
congratulations you guys I'm proud of
you did you hear that Mom did you hear
what Dave just said yeah very excited
Ken Coleman's on the number one podcast
in the world I got to go call myom andad
in any category it's not some nuanced
you know
Southern uh double wide trailer
broadcast uh number one we're the number
one in that right no this is the whole
freaking thing uh the Numero Uno and
that's big deal I got a few Elementary
School teachers that are having a heart
attack right now if they're here yeah
well I guarantee you I do but my speech
teacher is not my speech teacher Mr
burner oh Mr burner Mr burner and uh in
ele in uh uh middle school he was a
believer seventh and eighth grade well
he sent me out there we had these things
called forensics yeah which was a speech
club and he went around to other schools
and gave memorized speeches or did
debates or whatever yeah and uh Mr
burner knew I could talk he wasn't sure
I could do anything else but he knew I
could talk and here I am making a living
who knew it so way to go Mr burner this
is to you well
done H open phones at8 825 5225 we'll
start this hour with Canada Megan is
with us Hi Megan how are you I'm doing
fantastic thank you so much for taking
my call I greatly appreciate and it's an
absolute honor to speak to both of you
today you too what's up um so I have a a
quick question it's um I have a
brother-in-law who is being completely
enabled by my mother-in-law and
father-in-law he is currently still
living at home he's almost 40 years old
and he has some uh he has a drug
addiction problem as well as he's
currently not working
and my major concern is that you know my
my in-laws are getting older they're
almost 80 um and we recently purchased a
house and it has a complete separate
in-law suite um they kind of their eyes
kind of got a little bit big when they
saw the new house that we purchased for
ourselves and they made mention like oh
isn't this just a lovely place for you
guys to potentially rent out later down
the line kind of hinting at the fact
that potentially um the brother could
potentially move in with us how do I
Polly explain to them I have zero desire
of him moving into our house you don't
your husband does it's his mother not
yours absolutely I agree with you um
your husband have a backbone or does he
need to run down to Walmart and pick one
up I think I need to buy him one for
Christmas okay I'll three I'll three at
Walmart I'll three yeah yeah so apparent
listen if you if you do it you're going
to be the Wicked Witch of the West until
they
die okay because one thing about
enablers they don't think they're
enablers they think they're
nice and if you don't participate in
their enabling by definition you are not
nice so you see this with very very
clear eyes your husband does your
husband agree with you I'm not kidding
does your husband needs to head this off
at the pass what's what's what's
brother's name first name Joe Joe Joe
good okay so brother just just catches
you know MIM M and Papa at the at the
dinner table and says hey just to let
you guys know uh Joe's not moving in
with us as long as I'm
breathing that's her husband's
job okay you don't say a word you sit
there and just kind you sit there and
kind of dab the corners of your eye like
you're
crying okay you don't say a word what
was the question Megan there's no way to
what for me to politely bring this up no
no why do you keep going back to you do
you not why you have to do it because I
have the backbone I know but you can you
can share yours with
him my wife does it all the time she
says sick
them that is true that is true well in
Stacey's case too she's as sweet as she
can be but but she makes it very clear
what her position is on some things at
times and and it that means it's clear
that I need to get on that page yeah you
don't have a brother-in-law problem you
have a husband problem that's exactly
right so do you pick those up at Walmart
too new ones or do that that's a whole
separate call yeah no I mean get with Dr
John delone your marriage counselor or
whatever else but I honestly I would
just say honey if I talk to your mom
about this this is not going to go well
they're going to be angry with me and I
don't want that it is your family it's
actually your job and uh I'm going to
encourage you uh I'm going to give you a
stiff cup of coffee a stiff kick in the
rump and you're going to go talk to your
mother and dad and at some point when it
comes up gently and be kind and just say
you know you don't want to be as rough
as I was a minute ago but just Mom and
Dad look we've got this house and I you
know you guys were all big eyed about
the movie about you know us having an
apartment to rent we might rent it out
someday but we won't be renting it out
to Joe yeah and you need to know that
ahead of time and Joe you know I go and
tell Joe Joe you're not moving in I love
you but I hate what you've become and
I'm not going to participate in your
drug addiction your laziness and your
parasitical involvement with Mom and Dad
you're a parasite you need to you need
to you know I I'll help you I'll coach
you I'll love you and help you get up on
your feet and actually become a man and
go be somebody but you ain't living in
my house
dude okay and that's your husband's
job 100% of the time that you say one
word or even agree using your
eyes you're going to get blamed for this
don't let this land on you it's not your
fault okay make him do it he he can do
it cuz he does agree with you but he
comes from enablers which are nice
people and they build a family script
that anyone that goes against nice
people is by definition mean people and
that's that's running around in your
husband's head M am I
wrong no you're not wrong yeah and
you're not mean and you're not crazy and
you're not you know you are sweet and
you're being protective of of your own
home space which you should be this is
called Boundaries and when you set up
boundaries for people that don't have
any they generally don't like it so you
don't need to be the one doing it this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one best sing author is my co-host today
you know Ken I was bragging on on our
team here for um the number one podcast
position on Apple uh but I really should
brag also on our listeners because one
of the things that has really
substantially moved the needle no
kidding for real I'm not J I'm not
jazzing with you it's the truth is that
we started asking you guys and then you
did it to subscribe to whatever format
you're listening YouTube podcast you
know whatever it is subscribe and to
review and leave a five star and to uh
share a link or click the share button
if the format you're using the platform
you're using has a has a share button so
sharing and subscribing and reviewing
affects these numbers
dramatically uh because it lets other
people listen tells other people we're
here it's great marketing uh you know
you guys are great marketing thank you
for sharing so like when you read a good
book uh you tell other people you got to
read this book man or you see this movie
you go man you've seen that movie that's
great same thing with the podcast and we
thank you for that you guys a bunch of
you in this calendar year more than ever
before have shared have subscribed and
have positively reviewed us thank you
for that yes we really appreciate you
there's a reason that we're number one
on Apple right now thank you thank you
thank you for that and I'll keep
bragging on all of you so I can keep
saying it over and over and over because
it's Pretty stinking cool all right
Steph is in Chicago hi Stephen welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hey gentlemen how are you doing today
better than I deserve what's up yeah I
um so when I was young um I lost both my
parents when I was younger and I
received a trust um as a result of that
and I kind of just wanted to pick your
guys' brains and how I can continue to
grow those assets um right now I'm 26
and I kind of have no idea which
direction to kind of move with those
okay how much how much did you get uh
84,000 and you're in charge of the
entire Trust
uh yes I work with a financial adviser
on it I know but you're in charge of it
yes correct yeah you tell the financial
adviser what to do he doesn't tell you
what to do yes okay that's the way it
should be by the way the first thing
you're looking for in financial people
and you you got to be careful because
the way you use your words around me
I'll catch on okay um the thing you're
looking for is the heart of a teacher
their job is to give you ideas and tell
you why those ideas might work that's
called teaching
their job is not to do everything and
you go oh I got a guy that takes care of
everything that's how people lose all
their
money okay because the guy that takes
care of everything never
does ever ever that's you know you read
hear these Sports guys you know make NFL
player makes 10 million bucks sign
signing bonus he's 22 years old 23 years
old and uh you know then he's 30 years
old and he's bankrupt cuz I got me a guy
that's what they tell me when I'm
working with them in the NFL I got me a
guy to which I always yell at them
you're the guy okay you follow me I do
it at a distance because they're big but
yeah um so yeah you you you're the guy
you you you understand so that's first
thing then the second thing is what are
you going to invest in after you learn
about it that you're comfortable with
now um you know and and I guess then the
third thing is is I would set up your
lifestyle if I were you where you don't
need any this money where you work earn
your own money and you you know you're
building your own life yeah and that's
what I'm trying to continue to do and I
guess um Dave since I've kind of known
this in the back of my mind that I have
it um you know I feel guilty for kind of
being in this position of having that
and no reason to feel guilty unless you
live off of it and become a useless
trust fund baby then you should feel
guilty that's what I don't want um to
happen but um hey let me St let me give
you three questions that you don't have
to answer on the spot right here but I
think this is a good exercise you may
have answered them I would I would give
you these three questions to get clear
answers on and it'll help you do what
you need to do with this money and
there's no guilt what do I want to do
that's professional what do I want to
have that's personal and then what do I
want to give and that's that's about
others Focus I think that those are
three big 30-year questions and if you
get the answers to those I would want
this money to be able to advance those
very clear big goals what do I want to
do what do I want to have that's some
material stuff that that matters to you
and then what do I want to give I think
and you could add anything to those
three questions but those are real
simple to be able to have a long-term
Vision that this money can now fuel
that's the way I want you to come at it
so Stephen I'll tell you kind of like we
told our kids when they were your age
and uh or they a little bit younger than
you we sat down and we showed them what
the Ramsey net worth had become I said
um this is not you hit the lottery
moment because as for our house we serve
the Lord and what that means in this
moment of you seeing our net worth for
the first time because they didn't grow
up thinking they were rich kids we
didn't allow that although they were
um we they grew up you know having to
work and learning learn learn a skill
and become useful human beings um and so
I said you what you've got with this
money is not the blessing of never
having to do anything what you got is a
tremendous responsibility
you are going to be what I am a manager
of God's money for him and his glory and
if you are not going to manage this
money for him and for his glory you will
not be getting the
money and so that's how this goes that's
how I told our kids and so what that
does if you step back and you say my job
is to manage this for the legacy of my
family whoever it was that did such a
great job with money that left it to you
you want to honor that by by furthering
this and the first way you do that is
you you you earn your own living and you
don't live out of this money number two
you you take this money and you manage
it you well like you were managing it
for someone else that you cared deeply
about uh which would be the memory the
legacy of the family for the Lord
however you want to view that and so and
that means you get with someone that has
the heart of a teacher then I'm
investing it if I'm you basic stuff I
would start with a series of just good
growth stock mutual funds just very
simple stuff like this was your
401k like you had 800,000 in your 401k
and lots of people have 800,000 in the
401K by the way so I just started like
that and I put my personal 401k and a
lot of my mutual fund investing in four
types of Mutual Funds growth growth and
income aggressive growth and
international I personally spread mine
out 25% in each of those four and I look
for mutual funds that have long track
records that have outperformed the
S&P and that's how I pick them and my
financial advisor my ramsy smart Vestor
Pro that I work with that has the heart
of a teacher will bring me three or four
funds that meet those guidelines we'll
discuss those three or four and based on
his input and uh his work to get it to
that point I will choose then what I
want to do with my money
and he will go do with my money what I
tell him to do and that's what you're
supposed to do you see the difference
yeah definitely so and you go ahead and
put in your corner a tax person that you
trust you put in your corner an estate
planner that you trust you put in your
corner an insurance person that you
trust all of these people are in the
financial Arena which means all of them
are required to have the heart of a
teacher
when I hire a lawyer in a lawsuit or in
some other situation their job is not to
tell me what to do although some of them
took that class in law school and
occasionally they get fired by me for
doing that CU I'm not putting up with an
arrogant but attorney so you're going to
do what I tell you to do in my situation
but you're here to advise me and teach
me the law in that situation that's
different than my lawyer said I have to
my lawyer don't say I have to do nothing
he has to do stuff I said that's the way
that works same thing with you dude
that's what I want you to do on all this
and I'm not being a smart ellic but the
the point is that people get this stuff
backwards because we feel insecure and
lacking in knowledge and so we want to
trust the professional turn our back and
walk away MH and that's how the patient
dies on the table don't do that you stay
in the surgery you want to learn how
this happens you get your hands in the
blood and guts and you make sure this
stuff goes you're managing it you're the
manager these other people are advisers
they're helpers they're teachers and
build you a little board of directors
and you're going to be worth $8 million
in about 20 minutes if you'll do this
time you're 40 this will be 8 million if
you watch what you're doing this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast preapproval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
whole home buyer Edge from Churchill
gives you an advantage over those other
guys go to Churchill mortgage.com today
to learn
[Music]
more
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you're listening to us
live the Ramsey cash giveaway ends at
midnight tonight December the 20th
Wednesday if you register for free no
purchase necessary you uh will be
registered to win and possibly be one of
the winners for the $5,000 grand prize
giveaway Ramsey solutions.com
giveaway Jared is in Milwaukee hi Jared
welcome to the Ramsey Show thanks thanks
sure what's
up I've got some cash stashed aside for
eventually a house purchase um right now
I'm 23 years old renting an apartment
I'm single I make about 90,000 a year um
my monthly rent is right around $1,000
I've got around
$270,000 saved up for a house I just
don't
know you are a stud man way to go I'm so
proud of
you thanks I you know how weird that is
right not really it's weird it's a good
weird is it when I call you weird around
here it's a compliment cuz normal's
broke and stupid in America okay you
don't want to be normal you're amazing
man way to go thanks 275,000 where is it
under the
mattress it's it's all Bank Local Credit
Union right now it's making about 4% not
bad that's okay so I mean in all reality
that 4% covers my monthly rent right now
I just don't know if there's a better
route better plan better something that
I can use that money for to make more
what's your timeline when do you think
you're going to do the uh do the house
purchas
probably in the next three years okay
all right well here's the number here's
some numbers for you okay there's really
there's really no me medium investment
investing there's conservative which is
in a savings account and you're not
going to lose any money but you're not
going to make much money which is where
you are right now you're making 4% okay
and there's nothing wrong with that if
you park it there for the next 3 years
you're not going to make a bunch of
money on your money but you're not going
to lose any money and it turns out we
already figured out what the secret
sauce is it's Jared you're the secret
sauce it isn't the
investment none of that money none of
that 275,000 is in there because you are
some kind of uh big- time investor it's
in there because you're a big time saver
right yep okay so you're the secret
sauce so it's okay if you leave it there
you follow me yep now the other end of
the spectrum is you could move some or
all of the money towards something like
an S&P 500 Index mutual fund all right
if you did that this year I haven't
pulled it up in a while I'll try to do
it hey Ken pull up S&P 500 see what the
return is for the year while I'm yaking
I I think it's north of 15% for the year
right now okay but the mutual funds are
that S&P follows what the stock market
does the stock Market is up this
calendar year from January to December
you follow me yep I think it is I'm
pretty sure it is and um last time I
looked was a couple months ago it was up
15% for the year and so uh but anyway it
could go down though if it went down 10%
you'd lose like 20,000 bucks 26% 26.2
for the year for the year yeah I thought
it it's way up that's that's not
realistic okay well yeah we've had a big
jump the last we had a big jump because
interest rates went down and we got a
election coming all this stuff so okay
you but anyway the SNP has averaged
about 11.6% since it began so what I do
Jared is I'll throw money in there
knowing I could lose some but if I make
10 instead of
four that's pretty good that's another
6% on your 300,000 so that's another 20
grand or 30 grand you're making on your
money okay yep okay so if you want to
move some of other but but you you got
to understand that can go down here's
your actual numbers
99% of the fiveyear periods any
potential consecutive five years 99
times out of 100 have made money in the
S&P since it began okay safe bet if
you're going to leave it alone five
years or more that you're going to be
okay to put your money in that okay 67%
two out of three times it makes money on
a threeyear
period okay yep so you got a one and
three chance you lose some money with
your plan if you move some that way now
I have been investing a long time and
I've got a little extra money this is
very precious money for you and you're
young and this is your first ride so I
don't know if you can emotionally handle
losing $10,000 on
this okay but if you can and you want to
move half of it over into S&P you could
do that fairly safely with a three-year
Horizon but you don't have to do that
you you can just sit where you are
because truthfully the reason you have
money is because of Jared not because of
some sophisticated Financial
strategy okay and so I you know let me
just tell you I think in your case if I
woke up in your shoes I would just tell
you keep it that in that 40%
account if you're just dying to try
something move 50 Grand or something
over in on S&P but um but I I just leave
it there I just think I don't want you
to become disillusioned uh because you
are you've worked so hard for this money
yeah and I have the feeling he's
planning to save up for an all cash
purchase it feels like that we didn't
ask but he's already got 270 so at that
rate what's he going to save over the
next three years a lot yeah I mean what
if you're Jared's mom and dad and you're
listening touchdown yeah way to go
you raised an adult freaking amazing
he's not a victim he's not whining he's
not afraid of work God that's awesome
Lord help us get us more Jareds that's
awesome way to go man well done Trish is
with us in Maine hi Trish how are
you hi Trish I'm doing well good what's
up how are you better than I deserve how
can I
help um
so I just I sold my house over the
summer and I paid off all of my debt
except for my Jeep and I got my CD and
I'm a truck driver and I was just
wondering how to manage my money uh like
where to put it um I do want to purchase
a house in the future you're living in
the truck right
now I am okay cool driving over the road
we got a
sleeper yeah look at you girl how old
are you
I'm I'll be 39 in January how many
states you've been in the last
year um all of them except for
California Oregon and um Washington yeah
California made it no fun for a trucker
to come in there didn't they yeah oh not
really there's there's some taxes and
stuff you be careful there girl anyway
way to go you saw you're seeing the
world I like you how much do you make
Trish uh well I mean I get paid by the
mile so it varies I mean what are you
going to make in the C what you pay
taxes on
23 uh probably 55 60,000 okay good for
you and you're see in the world all
right pretty much yeah so what's your
question um how to what am I doing with
my income um I know from like uh I have
to save a certain amount and I have to
put invest a certain amount and then I
have the rest but obviously you got a
che you got a cheep debt what have you
got any money to pay off the
Jeep um I do the only reason why I
didn't pay it is because the payoff
amount is the same as the remainder of
my payments and I just at the time
remainder of your
what the remainder of the payments that
I have I only have like two years left
of no that no do you have the money to
pay off the Jeep
today yes I do pay it off when you get
off the phone that's step one step two
is you need to have an emergency fund of
3 to 6 months of expenses do you have
that done if you pay off the Jeep do you
still have that yes you got a lot of
money you're doing good okay then you
start putting 15% of your income into
retirement get online at Ramsey
Solutions and click on smartvestor for a
smartvestor pro near you they'll sit
down with you and help you get started
with your first Roth IRAs and you can
rock and roll with that if you got a
401K with a trucking company you may
want to look at that but I want you
putting
15% of your income into retirement with
a paid off Jeep and an emergency fund
and you're on your way
have a have fun out there drive safe
merry
[Music]
[Applause]
Christmas if you're like most people
your home is your most valuable asset
and when you want to make improvements
it can feel like everything costs too
much takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com and get up to
35% off that's blinds.com to learn more
rules and restrictions May
apply
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
5225 that young lady driving in SE every
state but um I guess I somehow I had a
my head over Road was making more than
50 Grand 60 Grand uh well they
absolutely can so giving an idea you
know depends on the company but Walmart
famously was hiring drivers last year uh
for 990,000 starting pay so it depends
on the company depends on the experience
but yeah you she will eventually make
more than that I would guess that in her
situation it's either the company or
it's her status so she's early on okay
that could be it's on the low side
Caitlyn is with us in Chicago hi Caitlyn
how are you hi good how are you um so so
I've got a question around renting for
another year or buying in a few few
months so 26 years old right now I rent
with my husband and we've got a
three-year-old and we've got 125,000
saved but that's like all of our
savings okay what's your household
income um well like every month after
like taxes and everything we take about
take home about
8,500 okay so that's 100,000 a year so
you're making about 140 probably okay
and um 130 something like that um how
much debt do you have nothing nothing no
car debt nope nope no student loan debt
nope good for you what do you'all do for
a
living uh I work for McDonald's and then
my husband works for like a digital
marketing firm okay what do you do for
Mickey
D I'm on the menu team over at corporate
corporate yeah I know you're corporate
probably at Chicago okay cool good for
you well done all right good um what's
the house price we're looking
at like
424 is is like what would be get us like
enough bedrooms enough space and
something that's like not a fixer
uer I like that plan so here's a couple
rules we use uh to cause people to be in
a healthy situation not a I got house
feifer lost my mind and did something
stupid situation okay so rule number one
is to be dead free which you are rule
number two is when you make your down
payment you need to retain enough to
call your emergency fund which is 3 to
six months of household expenses we'll
call that 15 grand 20 grand and your
situation okay so you got a 100 or so to
put down
now Okay the third thing is don't take
out ever never take out more than a
15-year fixed rate where the payment is
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
that's the max you can qualify for
almost twice that much but that doesn't
mean you need to be that stupid don't do
that keep it conservative so you can get
the house paid off unless than 15 years
that's the goal okay okay because that's
a key to Building Wealth longterm it's a
it's a pinch shortterm but I think all
of that will still work for you then the
last thing is if you can figure it out
and you're right on the bubble on this
one if you can make it your uh make a
down payment of 20% or more with a
conventional Fanny May loan you avoid
PMI private mortgage
insurance and PMI cost you about $75 a
month per 100,000 borrowed so we're
talking about $225 a month on
$300k that's pretty substantial and all
that is is foreclosure insurance that
you buy for the mortgage company if they
have to foreclose on you it covers them
it does nothing for
you okay but if you put down 20% you
have an 80% loan to value ratio LTV then
you avoid having to buy that ridiculous
PMI all right so I'd love for you to do
that one it's not mandatory but you can
see from the numbers that it's a you
know it's a really cool thing to avoid
that um yeah but the other things I
would call mandatory for your future
wealth building and I think you're right
on the bubble of being able to do all
that depending on when you do this and I
would go ahead and purchase some time in
the this coming Cal in 24 now if rates
right this second have been coming down
for the last uh 30 or 45 days all right
uh and people are all worried about
interest rates interest rates interest
rates interest rates listen don't worry
about interest rates what I want you to
do is buy a house the way I just
described that's what I think will cause
you to win and you marry the house and
you date the
rate you follow me right so you're
buying the right house and then if the
rates come down just
refinance yeah yeah if you get a six and
some change right now and they come down
to three or four
refinance okay but you still got the
right house so you marry the house and
you date the rate the mortgages are
temporary houses are a lot less than
temporary they're not permanent but
they're a lot less than
temporary yeah okay I got to ask her two
questions Dave okay all right first uh
earlier today Caitlin we're very excited
proud of the team we were rated the
number one podcast on all of app iTunes
this is stuff people want to know from a
Mickey D's menu expert anything exciting
coming out in 2024 on the new menu I'm
not asking tell you're allowed to tell I
know you can't tell us just can what can
you tell us people want to know I don't
know I don't know you do know but you
don't know what you can say well there
there's something exciting coming can
you tell us that yes or no tell us
everyday is exciting oh great corporate
answer all right last question yeah you
should run for office that was a great
answer uh that would work on Meet the
Press every Sunday all right uh next
question what's your all-time favorite
menu
item probably double cheeseburger or the
Nugget the Nugget interesting all right
mine's the Big Mac the Big Mac special
sauce lettuce cheese I mean that's it
that's that's child of the 80s right
there so there you go child of the 70s
too get you that one in
1976 it was a116 to get a Mac and a CO
small
way and we'd go through drivethru when
we were in high school wow yeah that's
that that's a you're old Ramsey your dad
come right and I'm proud of it I'm alive
shut
up by the way Dave you were talking to
about a 15-year rate today right this
moment it's at 6.2 that's what I thought
in a low six but I mean it was up seven
and some change just 30 days ago that's
right yeah so uh we're seeing the r
Trend in the right direction and what's
happening is here's what's weird it's
Christmas time which is a weird time for
people put houses on the market but a
bunch of people listed their houses in
the last 3 weeks without question the
inventory is coming back up so we may
see a real estate Revival in the spring
um which you can pretty well count on
the FED trying to make sure that Biden
stays in office and drops this rate uh
what are you saying Dave I'm just saying
that there's a there's a plan here
there's a plan that sus as George would
say suspect apparently that's a thing to
say sus now but you know there you go I
don't know it's about like that St
forgiveness thing
he you say why in the crap did they run
these rates up so they could run them
down and look like Heroes oh there's
that yeah okay what do I know yeah had
to stop his inflation so then he then he
can be the hero stopping the inflation
be the hero and stop and get rid of the
U all caused by yeah self self-induced
yeah okay what do I know yeah I'm a
little cranky about I have I have the uh
I have the gift of cynicism spiritual
gift you do you do I have insight into
these things I kind of got I kind of got
uh into that higher rate on my uh on my
savings account on that uh that that uh
it's going down a little disappointed
about thought about that in years I was
telling one of my buddies about this so
in 1981 I was in college right my
grandpa who never touched the stock
market with a 10ft pole but he saved
like a crazy man he saved everything he
made uh had money markets he was so
proud of his money markets over at the
savings and loan I got money markets
rates you know what he had dad got money
market paying 14% at one point yeah no
joke that was crazy I mean that's a
savings account paying 14% in 1981 but I
mean fixed rates on mortgages were 17
and a half yep so there you go that's a
what a wild world it's like a credit
card or something yeah yeah yeah distant
memory foggy way back there but I could
still see him talking about it with a
gleam in his eye he was so excited that
his money markets were performing at
such a high rate the only time in
history you saw a double digit money
market rate return over 10% I'm guessing
though he wasn't carrying a mortgage or
or would oh he Ain seen he a seen any
debt but he also didn't touch stock
market cuz he was a child of the Great
Depression he was 26 when the market
speculative yeah he wasn't going to
touch that that's gambling I'm not doing
that he saved every dime he made though
he was amazing he's a good
man wow this is how it's done boys and
girls that puts this hour of the Ramsey
Show in the
[Music]
books
[Applause]
[Music]
la
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one bestselling author of the book
paycheck to purpose is my Host this hour
the phone number is
88255 225 Merry Christmas to you America
we're glad you're here Kate's in San
Antonio Texas hi Kate how are you Hi how
are y'all better than we deserve what's
up um yeah so basically I kind of like
just started uh I just got introduced to
you I started binging everything and I'm
going to like try to be as fast as
possible um but and and so I'm trying to
get working on the baby steps um I'm
like yeah so my problem is income it's
really not that great and so I'm wanting
to increase it and I found some like
courses that I think could really help
me increase my income so that I can
really like get ahead on this stuff but
um unfortunately like it kind of does
involve I guess still borrowing money a
little bit um and I don't know if that
might be a good investment to make or if
I should like I don't know try to figure
out something
else okay let's start with some facts
what do you make right now and what are
you doing to make that what's your
income oh yes yes sir so right now um I
make like 30,000 um with one job I work
you know I have a day job I have a job
on the weekends that I make a couple
hundred with as well um what are you
doing what's what what kind of work for
the
30k um I work for the state okay doing
what yeah like clerical work cleric okay
what what are these classes you're
thinking about so it's a business
analytics class and I did a lot of
research in my area and the salary for
that um can be up to you know 30 to 30
to 60 or sorry not 30 50 to
60,000 um entry levels what's the class
cost the class cost 9,000 you don't need
to go in debt for that well I I don't I
don't have any way to save for it really
um cuz everything that I'm doing is kind
of keeping me at a Baseline and paying
off like the base of my debt right now
how much debt do you have
now like 30,000 on what for student
loans my car and's your degree like oh
um I didn't finished that was just for
one semester 30,000 for one semester
well not sorry for one year not one one
semester still okay wow how much of the
car how much is the car of that
debt uh 10,000 M so what are you
25 yeah okay all right you sound like
sounds like about about the takes about
that long to make a mess this big
okay you're okay yeah I'm trying to get
out of it that's why I was here here's
what we need to do we need to back up
the re the thing that's motivating you
is I need a better job I need a better
career field that's what's motivating
you and I agree with that motivation is
that
correct um yes sir basically yeah I
don't want to be a secretary at the
state making 30 I want to be doing
something that makes 60 80 90 or 100
that's what your that's what was running
through your brain that's what got us
here it wasn't you woke up one morning
and go you know since I was six I always
wanted to do business analytics that
didn't come up you just you're looking
for some more money am I right yes sir
okay yes sir so that means you have
called on the perfect day because Ken
Coleman's goal in life is to help you
find the highest paying possible job
that you are passionate about and good
at and love going to work every day not
just more
money and it's not business analytics
for you so you're on Ken ready go yeah
well I think you've done a lot of
thinking about the type of work that you
love you thought about it when you went
into college what what do you want to do
and don't get hung up on job title what
kind of work would you love to do if you
knew you couldn't fail and we got you
fast forward into the type of work what
kind of work do you want to
do um yes so so really um I would love
to uh be a educator and I did work in
education um that's kind of also what
was um what was helping me like with
school and stuff I was like okay I can
get this job and I can be an educator
but um teaching who teaching those
people
what um for me it was uh typically about
middle AG to high school kids okay
middle school high
school yes yes sir middle school high
school I'm very passionate about like
you know geography social studies and
World languages so I would really like
to um teach them those about those
things so the problem with that is or
it's not a problem the requirement for
that is you got to have a degree and yes
sir we can't afford school right now so
as long as we know what the long-term
play is
now we begin to back into this and we go
okay we know what it takes to get out of
debt and we're going to walk you through
the baby steps we can help you there but
we've got to take care of that now so
that we position ourselves for the next
yeah so that uh the 35y old Kate is in
high school teaching
geography yes sir now what are the steps
to get there yes so we got to get out of
Deb so we got to get out of debt first
right we can't go to school We're not
gonna get a student loan I just pulled
up a headline today millions of people
are not paying their student loan
payment right now so I don't want you to
do what everybody else is doing because
what everybody else is doing is going to
make you further broke y all right so
we've got to get out of debt now and
then we've got to cash flow school so
that you can come out and make the
median income for teachers in the United
States right now it's about 61,000 but
that's that could be higher depending on
where you teach the the the right next
class you take is going to be after
you're debt free Y and it's going to be
to towards becoming a geography teacher
in high school that's right that's the
next class you take it's not a business
analytics class and you're going to pay
cash for that class when you take it in
the meantime what are we going to do
every high paying side job that you can
come up with you don't need to see the
inside of a restaurant unless you're
working there you don't need to go on
vacation you need to go get your life
back cuz right now all this crap owns
you you don't own it and so you're about
to get in gear I want you working 80 90
hours a week every high paying side
hustle I don't want you taking anything
cute or fun on the side I want you to
take stuff that makes a lot of money as
long as it's legal and moral and you're
not ashamed to do it I want you to go do
it right now I want you to make as much
if you walk dogs or you pick up dog poop
I don't care what it is I want you to
make as much money as you can make in a
short period of time Ready set go cuz
the faster you get this debt paid off
and the faster you have $10,000 in the
bank is how fast you take the first
class and then the second class and then
the third class and then you become a
geography teacher don't worry about
overworking just before you die you will
pass out don't worry about it have at it
Go For It Go For It Go For It Go For It
hustle grind get it get it get it get it
that's how you do it hold on we're going
to have Austin pick up and get you
signed up for Ken's stuff we're going to
give it all to you free it's the uh get
clear assessment you need to take that
and make sure you're right on track and
the uh from paycheck to purpose book
we're going to give them both to you now
get it get it here's the deal Kate $2500
a month would knock this debt out in one
year it is doable doing it the way Dave
told you it's just working really hard
and putting every cent towards the de
get
[Music]
it
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one bestselling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
the book proximity principal both of
them number ones he also did an
assessment that we gave that last caller
called the get clear assessment it is
one of the most popular things in the
Ramsey store right now um a ton of you
come and uh get that I Ken what do we
charge for it's like 30 bucks 30 bucks
30 bucks and it takes you about uh 20 25
minutes to take the thing Max oh yeah
maybe less and then it spits out the
things you are good at the things you
love the pack passions and helps you
identify the direction you're going it's
not merely a personality profile we have
the dis personality profile in our
website on in our store as well and a
lot of people take that I love that I've
used it for almost 40 years now but we
this get clear assessment is a step two
step three steps beyond that in that it
takes that same kind of information and
then says okay here's where you'll end
up right yeah well it's a self-awareness
profile it let you know okay if I've had
a lack of confidence maybe I'm feeling a
little imposter syndrome this is what
I'm really good at in other words your
skills think of your skills or talents
as power tools then the second
measurement is passion in other words
what work do I look forward to and lose
myself in and then the third element is
what motivates me you ever wondered if
you need to go to a conference or read a
book to get motivated the answer is you
really don't motivation is about
understanding what gets you up out of
bed because these results fire you up so
the three elements come together we call
it a purpose statement and it shows you
what purpose and work looks like and
it's actually a job description if I
spend most of my day using what I do
best to do what I love to produce
results that matter to me guess what I'm
on fire and you have a famous phrase you
know you can't you can't light wet wood
it's the idea of you want to hire people
who know what they're supposed to be
doing with their life and that's what
this is it gives you great personal and
professional Direction yeah no I think
that probably comes from that guy that
came in one day and said I'm burning out
and I said that's impossible you were
never on fire I love that
story yeah and that's an example right
like he guy had no idea what seat on the
bus or even what bus he belonged on and
here's the key to that to get clear
assessment and why it matters if you
want to increase your income you'll do
it by increasing your impact and and
when you are attractive as a as a
candidate as a an actual employee
getting promoted that all leads to a
bigger paycheck which means we get
through the baby steps faster that's the
and in the hiring and firing sections in
entree leadership and we're teaching
businesses and leaders about proper
hiring and firing one of the things I
tell people to look for one of the 12
hiring principles is hire people whose
eyes light up that's right when they
talk about doing that job so good you
know you their body language changes
their octave changes their eyes sparkle
when they talk about the opportunity to
do that job that's the kind of thing you
need to be aiming at with your life yeah
and get clear helps you do that that's
why I'm so proud of this material it
does really well Ken wonderful stuff
thank you all right uh Daryl's in ronoke
Virginia hi Daryl welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave and Ken Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas sir how can we help
thanks for taking my call hey for my
question to make sense I'm going lead in
with a couple quick points um I'm
getting ready to turn to 53 I'm already
retired uh my wife is scheduled to
receive my pension um if I pass away
before her we just paid off our house we
are otherwise debt free and I'm 30 years
into a term life policy and I'm really
want to let go of it before it gets
expensive so I was just calling to see
if that would be the good thing for me
to
do how much have you got an
Investments how much do I have in
Investments yes sir uh I have my pension
from my my former employer that that's a
that's a pay stream to your wife if you
die I'm talking about Investments
I I have uh very little because we were
a kind of a lowincome family and I
didn't really have much to put away okay
30-year term is out there but 30-year
term is unusual you sure you have term
insurance you sure it's not whole life
or universal life no I saiding I'm I've
already I've already been paying in
because I when I was in the military and
I was 23 I started it yeah that doesn't
mean it's term insurance necessarily I'm
asking
it's unusual to have a 30-year term
insurance
policy you mean it's been level term for
30 years you've never had an increase in
pay in the premium no no the premium's
increased I'm just saying I'm 30 years
into it so every year it's
increased I it started out as at $5 a
month how often did it
increase uh about every five years I'm
up to $40 a month
now okay and for how much insurance
a 100,000 okay all right well the way
you answer your question is it sounds
like you did by a renewable term and
it's just your age is catching up with
you because of course statistically the
older you are the more likely you are to
die no kidding and they charge more for
it that's how that works right so
um it the way we answer the question is
if you die today without $100,000 in
term insurance with a paid for house the
kids are grown and gone or no kids um we
have one left in home but he's an adult
and he'll probably be out in the next
couple years okay well he might be out
tomorrow if you died
today because I'm not sure your wife can
afford
him without 100,000 because all she's
got to live on your pension
right um I have a a a a 457 of about
35,000 she is a teachers Aid uh teaching
assistant with the local schools and she
has a uh she has a retirement with these
um the state's
pension okay so if you die can she be
okay without the 100,000
mathematically not
emotionally um that's that's why yeah I
per without any um professional advice I
feel like she would but that's well I
mean it's pretty much math I mean her
pension your pension and no bills except
uh insurance on the house and taxes on
the house cuz there's no debt and she's
not going to be supporting a grown
person who he's going to be gone and uh
with your pension her pension and it
whether or not she works the little
teachers Aid job or not can she pay her
bills that's the question you know that
you don't need professional help for
that you can do a budget and look at
that yeah well we right now we um with
my pension and her pay and my VA
disability where your VA disability goes
away when you do right yeah she wouldn't
have that6 right now she wouldn't have
that so can she pay her bills on your
pension which she gets if you die
right to my calculation she could okay
and talk to her about that right before
you drop this cuz if $40 if $40 means
your wife is taken care of you keep the
the
policy but if it doesn't but if your
wife's taken care of without it and the
two of you agree that you know we're
paying for something we don't need then
you can release it because basically the
rule works like this the way you think
about it is this if the kids are cuz if
you got to feed kids if they're little
we got to pay debt if we have debt but
if the kids are grown and gone
everything's paid off house and
everything and we have a pile of
money and you die mathematically ain't
going to notice you don't have a pile of
money but you got a pension so
mathematically that's when you become
self-insured with financial planning so
you have you know for the rest of you
out there you know you're 56 the kids
are grown and gone the house is paid off
everything's paid off and you got
$700,000 in a 401k and you die I think
she can probably make it you've become
self-insured by investing and getting
out of
debt and your need for insurance and
raising the kids and kicking them out
that that's that's what does it okay but
if you V you know if you keep the
mortgage keep the kids and keep the debt
you you're going to need it you're going
to need to keep insurance so the
financial planning working the steps
that we talk about puts you in a
position that you're self-insured I
think you maybe you're right on the
bubble I mean if you told me you had
300,000 in a mutual fund in your 401k
I'd feel a whole lot better but you
don't in your case I think she's okay
but I want her to be okay with being
okay this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the Lobby of ramsy
Solutions on the debt free stage Joel is
with us hi Joel how are you man better
than I deserve very cool Merry Christmas
to you good to have Merry Christmas to
you where do you live Lancer
Pennsylvania lanaster awesome welcome
good to have you brother and how much
debt have you paid off $
65,535 And1 Penny love it how long did
this take 33 months good for you and
your range of income during that time
42,000 to
106,000 I like that in uh a little under
three years you triple your income
almost almost triple your income what in
the world what do you do for a living it
and you were you in that field before I
was in the field during and uh I did
take a side job for about 3 weeks at
McDonald's and uh during that time
people from town went through the
drive-thru and they were asking me what
are you doing there and I said I got
bills to pay there you go so I had a few
people ask me if I could help them with
it problems networks and long story
short I helped a lot of local businesses
wire up computer networks and do Wi-Fi
for large buildings yeah good for you
and they made some good that's some
great side money yeah good side hustle
using your uh using your your uh skills
excellent job what kind of debt was the
65,000 yeah so uh I had two credit cards
and a lot of healthcare debt and a bunch
of uh stuff pop up from a divorce so I
just had a lot of surprises along the
way and during my uh debt free process
um I had a lot lot of health issues so I
had a lot of ongoing expenses so the
majority of my debt was actually paid
off in the last six months wow okay how
you doing now healthwise much better
good I'm glad getting all debt was
probably the best medicine it is good
medicine uh your your body doesn't have
to carry around that stress yeah and
it's heavy very heavy yeah so that's
very cool very cool and you get the
health issues behind you that you end up
with more money cuz that's expensive
yeah yeah I'm sorry you went through
that but I'm glad you're here now well
done well done so what started this
whole process 33 months ago with the
Ramsey process that's a good question um
it actually started with a really low
point in my life um woke up one day and
I was separated so I was scared it was
the first day of the lockdown um so one
of the first things I did is I actually
emailed the show someone reached out and
responded and said they would hook me up
with a uh Ramsey coach your wife leaves
on the first day of the lockdown yeah
her timing sucks yep
wow so to I actually it was a four-year
process but the first year I had to get
I had to move on from that um but
regardless I started with that Financial
coach and she really calmed me down and
you got one of the Ramsey coaches yeah
okay and um you know she pointed out
that I didn't have to pay all the
expensive money for a divorce so I found
a lawyer that did a pro bono oh wow yeah
okay um so from there and the secret I
found get on debt is I had to surround
myself with people so whether it was
support groups going biking with the
guys just finding more work getting to
know people got involved with the church
I had just found myself surrounded and
the most important people were my
parents my father's actually here with
me and to be honest I think a big part
of the reason why I got out Deb CU my
parents brought me upright yeah yeah
well I mean you you your life has been
completely turned upside down and
transformed and in the middle of that
you said I I am not carrying this debt
wow I mean you're facing health issues a
divorce and a pandemic uh I mean God
Almighty you got the fouchy quarantine
and a dadgum separation and divorce all
in the same lick and that had to mess up
your income simultaneously and was your
health bad about the same time quite bad
I mean you got like a perfect storm crap
going on there that's amazing wow so I I
want to follow up there because I think
there are a lot of people that are
watching and listening to your story
right now and uh they got a lot of other
factors going on in their life that are
bad and maybe causing the money issues
and they look at getting out of debt and
it seems insurmountable I'm just curious
with everything that Dave just laid out
that you shared that you were going
through how much did the focus on the
baby steps the focus to get out of baby
step to how much did that help you
overcome all that other garbage that you
were dealing with did it play a factor a
huge factor to be honest I was I was in
the first and second step going in and
out you know there were some months
where I deplete that, emergency fund um
and again going back to people and
surround myself you know there are some
months that were tough so people from
the church would feed me Mom would feed
me stuff like that and God show up in
amazing ways um I should have actually
owed more debt but I even had a local
church step up and help me pay off some
of my medical bills so God was behind
every corner of it that's powerful wow
look at you well done sir I'm proud of
you you're a hero you fought through
some pretty serious stuff there it it's
amazing I mean and now you're the other
side of all of it wow yeah and a funny
fact actually when I first started off
with my debt-free journey I didn't have
any feeling behind it like it was like
why I get out of debt there was just no
emotion behind that at the time so uh
one of the things I I said to myself
well if I get out debt I'm going to do
de free scream so here I am today oh so
that that's like your motivation down on
that stage we have to mark this puppy
got to have some reason to be excited
about this that's right we're going to
Nashville load up the truck and head to
Beverly I love it man good for you well
done well done I like that that's fun
well I you got to have something to aim
at it's one of the reasons we do this
people have this as a milestone the main
reason we do it is all the people
listening they're going to be inspired
because there's somebody out there right
now that's facing a job loss a health
problem and maybe even a relationship
problem all at the same time and they
probably have $65,000 in debt and look
at that and they then you're s up here
going you can do it just your life says
they can do it the way you've lived your
life so well well done proud of you very
well done um you did most of it in the
last 6 months yes so like half of it
just about half so you've been you've
been but your income came up from 42 to
106 so you had a great income you had
your health back you could see the end
of the finish line there's a light at
the end of the tunnel it's not a train
and so you're just running hard the last
6 months yeah it actually got a little
easier um because I figured out how to
do my side work more or actually work
less and get more done so it it it was
really neat it was a great learning
experience I got probably the best part
of the de free process was finding out
what I am made of and who I am that's
awesome I was going to ask what's the
emotional Kickback now that you're done
with this you're about ready to do the
scream so we're not the finish line yet
because I know that matters to you but
emotionally as you look forward in life
relationally professionally how do you
feel about yourself yeah um for the
first time I'm hopeful happy and um I I
can truly say that I'm resilient yeah
you are you are you are so the Ramsey
coaches that's one of the things about
the Ramsey coaches there's several
thousand of them that we've trained
around America some of them watching
right now some of our best and bright
some of our best coaches right here
right now came down to watch this from
inside our building but we've got them
all over the nation that have been
trained by us and one of the things they
do when uh I I occasionally get someone
intersect my life that's at the very
very very bottom where you were when all
that stuff happened and then you don't
have the strength to carry yourself
right then they just pick you up and
carry you through that so they get the
first few steps under you and just hold
you up and then once your feet start
touching the ground again you they'll
let you go and let you run but uh but
somebody sometimes you just got to have
somebody walk with you and you had a
coach step in and do that exact thing
with you I'm so proud of you guys well
done sir you and those guy the the coach
that helped you well done very very very
well done what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is do the
baby steps one at a time in order in
order there's a reason that one is
before 4 two is before three yep if the
next one doesn't make sense focus on the
current one yeah I like that good four
is after three for a reason yeah that's
good I like that very good all right
we've got the live and gift box for you
the baby steps millionaires book which
that's the next chapter in your story
The Total Money Makeover book to give to
someone that's struggling and hurting
Financial Peace University membership
all of that is for you to enjoy your
giveaway and our way of saying thanks
for coming down from Linker Pennsylvania
to do your dead free scream oh you're
amazing yeah you're amazing dude you're
a hero
$65,000 paid off in 33 months making 42
to 106 while life happened count it down
let's hear a debt-free Scream 3 2 1 I'm
de free there it
is that's the reason he's been pushing
for that moment boom
boom this is the ramsy shot
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're glad you're with us
Merry Christmas America Eric is in
Indianapolis Eric welcome to the Ramsey
Show gentlemen thank you for taking my
call it's an honor to speak with you
honor to speak with you what's up uh my
question is about a month ago my wife
and I decided that we were gonna take
the uh final amount of our mortgage
which was about 49,000 and pay it off
good um because
because we wanted to be debt free and we
didn't want it just sitting in our bank
account uh my concern is since that's
occurred I've not received anything from
the bank saying that I paid it off when
I look on my account online it's all
zeros I don't have any any sort of like
you know documentation other than that
and wonder if what kind of uh what kind
of mortgage did you have a traditional
mortgage or a bank loan or what uh it
was a VA um home loan okay with who
uh it was through Chase okay all right
uh Chase is uh roughly the size of the
federal government and about as
efficient okay so no no not to panic all
right number one you got zeros on your
account so that's a good sign I think I
think you have paid it off there's not
they don't there's not a question they
think you've paid it off you think you
paid it off right so correct technically
what needs to occur is they will file a
lean release a mortgage payoff at the a
release of deed a release of the deed of
trust a release of note at your federal
at your local County Seat Courthouse if
you live in Indie it's Indie okay
whatever whatever County you live in the
courthouse records the deeds and they
also record the mortgage
release that is the important thing
because that clears your title typically
they will send that to the deed when
they finally get around to doing it it
might take them 3 months okay I wouldn't
worry about it but they'll typically
send it to the register of deeds the
mortgage release the register will file
it stamp it send it back to them and
they'll send you send it to
you um if you are worried about it at
some point and you want to may maybe
they never sent it to you if you don't
have to have the receipt the only person
that has to have the receipt is the
courthouse it needs to be recorded as
being paid off a a lean release a
mortgage payoff release okay form at the
at the courthouse so um you know that's
what you want to verify has been done if
you want if you want to be nerdy about
it you want to call the courthouse or go
down there and say hey look up my
mortgage I've paid it off I want to see
if they have released the lean yet I
want to see if they've released the
mortgage and it's a one-page thing
you're going to get a little little bit
of it looks like a little uh legal
document that's one page long it'll be
folded up have a couple of red stamps on
it from being filed at the courthouse
and it'll be in your mailbox they'll
send it to you it's like the final paid
receipt kind of thing but all they're
doing is giving you a copy of what was
filed at the courthouse you can lose
that and it won't matter what matters is
that the register of deeds at the
courthouse doesn't lose it that
matters follow me understood okay so
check check check courthouse in uh end
of January if you hadn't heard anything
and start calling Chase and go dude
y'all need to release this mortgage what
the crap it's been it's been 90 days get
off your butt you know and and you know
start jacking on them a little bit cuz
they're they're truly are I mean it's
like working with a DMV I mean they're
just they're awful it's just they're
they're horrible these Mega banks are
just the worst um but that they will get
around to it they do have a system but
they are in no hurry to them it's one of
you're one of 80 bazillion people that
that they're doing this with yeah I love
that quote when you said they're bigger
than the federal government it's really
true the amount of people they're not
going to move quickly for you because
they honestly they have to be in a State
of Shock that someone actually paid
their house off that's part of it no
they they get they I mean it just but
it's you think about how many mortgages
Chase owns yeah that's a lot how many
credit cards Chase I mean how many
Towers full of people that work for them
and don't do their work most days
because they hate their job and you know
oh my God it's just
so that that's what you're dealing with
yeah Eva is in Brooklyn hi Eva welcome
to the Ramsey
Show hi David Ken thank you for having
me sure what's
up so I currently have credit card debt
at a 0% interest rate which will begin
occurring interest in May uh this was
before I was a listener and I'm
contemplating whether I should use
stocks or mutual funds to pay it off
alternatively I could become uh Morgan
cell intense about paying it off over
the next five months how much credit
card debt do you have $188,000 what do
you make a
year now I make
$150,000 good for you what do you do for
a
living I work in the architecture field
you're amazing well done how much have
you got in a single
stock so I have 30k in stocks and that
would uh be considered short-term gains
and then I have 160k in mutual funds
which would be longterm and then 40K in
retirement good for you well done uh I
pull enough out of the mutual funds
today pay it off
today okay it doesn't M it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter why are you kid
I mean you're playing footsie with this
stuff it's just a it's you got a
mosquito in your house you know just
shoot the
thing okay and I won't be charged more
taxes or fees you'll be pay you'll be
charged taxes on whatever you cash out
in those mutual funds you said it's
long-term gain so it' be a 15% gain on
the gain if there is any gain and I
don't know when you put the mutual funds
in what's your BAS is but we know 100%
of it's not a gain so let's say there's
a $2,000 gain on what you pull out uh
you might have $300 in taxes but I don't
give a crap get rid of this credit card
debt and cut up those stupid cards too
get out of that business I already have
yeah you're too smart for that business
get away from those people they're not
good for
you okay we'll do thank you yeah the
percentage interest doesn't matter the
idea of being free
matters what here's what's you know it's
just it's strange um
um we um we have
completely and I guess it's K because we
got trained by these ripoff Industries
with this debt products sure but um to
be normalized it's normal to have a
credit card it's everybody has a car
payment everybody has a mortgage
everybody oh shut up everybody's broke
and dumb too I don't want to do that
that we don't be everybody that's crazy
but we get so normalized with this stuff
that they have Tri us into only
analyzing our personal situation through
the lens of math yeah we are leaving out
the
emotional
relational
spiritual bandwidth that is being taken
up now let's just talk about this for
mean seriously this woman makes $150,000
a year she is smart yeah she's a
brilliant accomplished okay and the
amount of bandwidth she had to make a
phone call to a national radio show
because $188,000 at 0% is taken up
bandwidth when she's got hund and
something thousand bucks laying in a
mutual fund correct because the 0% we've
been taught you're exactly right this is
the Matrix she didn't want to be she
didn't want to feel dumb right she want
to feel wrong she want somebody expert
yeah you know somebody with a briefcase
20 mil from home to tell her what to do
right and so but but uh and I'm not
picking on her it's just the state of
our psyche is my point is to consider
this whole debt issue only through the L
of math is extremely naive M there are
so many more layers to
slavery than the simple
math slaves don't have choices slaves
lay awake at night worrying about where
they're going to eat slaves aren't
generous slaves have a different
personality style slaves keep a job that
they don't want to keep because they got
to pay the bills slaves are not even as
nice to their own
spouses the borrower is slave to the
lender there are ele elements there are
layers in our lives that are much bigger
than the 0% interest and yet we've been
taught that oh I mean you you could
borrow money at 0% and put in a mutual
fund it's just it we're not going to the
psychological weight the anxiety of that
is not even brought up that's right this
is really about freedom and and
everybody longs to be free to make a
choice to do what they want to do when
they want to do it you can't do that
when you're Shackled to debt that's the
big takeaway she's not Shackled In a way
that's limiting her but it's just
interesting point is in a in a in a
brain as smart as hers and she's just an
example I mean I think she's awesome I'm
I'm not picking her but in a brain as
smart as hers this 18,000 at 0% was
taking up way more space than she
realized it was that's exactly in her
brain that is not 0% that's correct
that's a very good point that's the
Matrix though they've trained us to
think well the number's good so put up
with it cuz it's a good number yeah I'm
smart because I got 0% yeah it's their
money I mean this couch I'm sitting on
0% 90 days same as cash at Rooms there
they went oh my gosh this is the Ramsey
[Music]
shop
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Merry Christmas we're so
glad you're with us Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one bestselling
author host of the Ken Coleman podcast
he is my co-host today open phones at8
8255 225 thank you for joining us Nate
is with us in Austin Texas hi Nate how
are
you uh what's up guys uh how you guys
doing today better than we deserve sir
how can we
help all right so I
am actually just turned uh 30 yesterday
I am happy birthday debt free oh thank
you I am debt free um I am on baby step
four five and six I guess
um
and my income is about 85 to 100,000 a
year um so my question
is I'm trying to save up for a house um
but I was thinking of going a different
route uh so I want to try and save up as
much money as I can for the
next two to three to four years right
and I want to basically buy a piece of
land and put a mobile home on it and
just try to pay it off in one big chunk
okay I can save up pretty
much 75 to 80% of my income you're
single I have a girlfriend
um but you're not my point is you're not
married and so you don't have to talk
her into living in a
trailer no no no okay so yeah so uh my
question
is should I try and save up as much
money as I can and try and just pay
something off
cash um if you bought a piece of land
and put an very very very very
inexpensive trailer on
it that would mean you'd have be living
rent free yeah and you could you know
very quickly then save up the money to
build a house and get rid of that
trailer but whatever you pay for that
trailer is going to be lost
money so we're not talking about $30,000
and we're not talking about $20,000
we're talking about $10,000 or
less yeah which ain't much
dude this is not a high standard of
living
here yeah correct yeah your your
girlfriend's not going to be impressed
with your
Abode yeah uh so we already kind of
talked about it um she doesn't really
care uh where she lives um well she's
not living there you
are yeah
but uh don't tell her this but I'm
probably going to marry her uh in 2024
uh oh okay now we got a different part
of the equation yeah that's what I've
been naming it in this whole
conversation your secret is you just us
and 30 million people yeah there's just
about 30 million of us that have to keep
your secret now but anyway but the uh uh
uh let me just tell you it's a whole
different equation for you to live in a
$10,000 trailer for 4 years or your wife
to live there for four years and I know
what she
says but I I you know it's just a
different equation you can count on it
guys we can sleep under a bridge it
doesn't bother us not me ladies are well
I know that's true and you know we we
get accustomed to the Finer Things We Do
Ken but uh I mean I'm Motel 6 is
roughing it I'm just saying but the uh
she may change her mind halfway through
this steel I agree with you my question
is why are we why are we in a I'm not
saying it's a hurry but why is this the
scenario why isn't it why not just rent
an apartment and save a bunch of money
if you're going to get married I'd rent
me too I don't get living out on the
land I would I might live out on the
land if it Me by myself just because I
love the math part of it oh no so yeah
so I'm actually am running um a duplex
in Austin and it's um I'm probably going
to be here for the next two to three to
four years uh cuz I rent is like
insanely low well yeah just stay there
with her then after you're married and
just and then you don't need the trailer
but just pay cash for the land and then
save up and pay cash for the build I'm
okay with that yeah that's not that's a
no-brainer I like that better yeah that
that makes a lot more sense but we've
had over the years Nate we've had a lot
of people that are listeners that have
done the I'm going to buy a piece of
land and live I'm G to build a barn with
a bedroom in it a barn dominium and live
in the barn while we build the house
I've had people do that I've had people
buy the $10,000 trailer put it on there
they do that um but I always answer
questions like what would I do if I were
in your shoes if I woke up and I was you
knowing what I know now and what I know
now is Sharon's not living in that
trailer yeah that's a great Point not
CUA she's a snob cuz she's not and not
cuz she wouldn't follow me anywhere cuz
she would because you know that you know
she'd do anything for me AB um oh my God
but yeah yeah follow me anywhere as long
as it's to the rits for the Four Seasons
but yeah but the uh
uh I'll follow you to the pool follow
you to the pool I'll follow you to the
resort you just know better I'll follow
you to the club the point is you just
know better I mean we're old and we've
done it we've been there done that on
the sacrifice thing so uh but yeah but
the point is um if I were at 20 and
married uh that would not that'd be a
different equation for me to do that by
myself than I would ask my wife to do
that that's the truth now some ladies
are perfectly fine with that and some
aren't and there's nothing wrong with
either Camp uh it's not a bad it's not a
moral judgment and it's not a snobbery
thing or anything like that I'm not too
good to do that so just keep your stupid
little trolling to yourself on that but
um that's not going to do with that it's
just got to do thinking through what is
realistic what is sustainable what am I
going to be able to do for a long enough
period of time that it has the effect
yeah yeah and it's going to take a
minute that's right Carla is in Lancing
Michigan Carla how are
you I'm good thank you Dave and Ken for
taking my call I really appreciate it
sure how can we help um I well my
question is I have an index annuity oh
no and I have an yeah I know and I have
a income for Life Rider on it um the I'm
thinking of that it might be a good idea
for me to exercise that but because I
don't know a lot about this I thought I
would call and get some expert advice
how much how much money you got in this
thing uh it's accumulation value is
103,000 how old are you I'm 75 you have
other money I'm debt free do you have
other money I have yeah I have 32,000 in
a high yield savings this is all your
money and I have a paid for home yeah
and I have a paid for home yeah um
I think the best route is going to be
for you to cash the whole thing out and
put it in a much better investment in a
good mutual fund I think but without
doing a detailed analysis on it I'm not
positive that's the case I would not do
what you're talking about the the the
it's not the best use of your 100,000
for you to take the lifetime I don't
think so sit down with one of our
smartvestor Pros click smartvestor at
ramsy solutions.com they can help you do
a det detailed analysis and show you
what your options are and then you'll be
able to make the decision they'll come
at this not telling you what to do but
with the heart of a teacher showing you
how all the math works and then you can
decide what's best I think it's going to
come out best for you to cash it and put
it in some mutual funds but I'm not 100%
sure this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
Merry Christmas America the Ramsey Show
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for home services
for over 40 years neighborly has an
exclusive network of trained local
service providers backed by the
neighborly Done Right promise if it's
not done right neighborly will make it
right it's a great company you guys
check them out visit neighborly decom
Ramsey right now and you can learn more
today's question comes from Joyce in New
Hampshire I am far from a helicopter mom
but I'm desperate to find extra guidance
for my son he lives in georia is 25 and
graduated sorry you you may protest too
much is that is that how the phrase goes
uh graduated from SCA that's Savannah
College uh of Art and Design for anybody
want to know what she's talking about in
2020 with a degree in digital in game
design he got a job in Esports industry
wow using his design degree loved his
job but in October 2022 20% of the
company was laid off the same has
happened at several companies since then
he's applied to literally thousands of
jobs I'll come back to to that in a
second for digital design project
management project management uxui jobs
he has had interviews and several times
he's made it to the final rounds only to
lose to people who were hired because
they had just a bit more experience than
him he's currently at a restaurant
exhausted deflated and just existing uh
as his mom it's been devastating to
watch I'm so proud of him for his
strength faith and resiliency however I
fear all of these will run out soon okay
uh couple things to point out here in
the question I'm not sure he's applied
to literally thousands of jobs that's a
long that takes a long time if he's done
that that's part of the problem uh this
is the online submission only where
folks you might as well be playing the
lottery go look up the odds on winning
the lottery and you know what I'm
talking about here this is you're
getting filtered out by AI you are
basically a nameless faceless person and
you're playing the job odds if what we
don't use AI at Ramsey but we'll have
15,000 applications this year yeah and
we're not going to look at all of them
yeah it's it's not I mean I mean we look
at all of them but like for half a
second yeah and so if you if that's all
you did to apply for a job here and you
count that as I've applied for thousands
the you you you've wasted your time 100%
And I hate to say that but that's the
reality you waste your time if all
you're doing is monster.com LinkedIn and
you're just dumping you're downloading
zip recruiter you're downloading
thousands of applications simultaneously
and all you're doing is just spraying
and praying that's exactly right second
thing that's jumping out to me in this
question is uh he's gotten to final
rounds a few times only to be hired by
someone a little more experience in him
so there's two things as his mom if you
want to give him some wisdom and
encouragement in this we want to point
out here number one he's made it to some
final rounds so get back up on the horse
Welcome to the Real World this is
competition where people are applying
for these jobs and you got to win and
you're not going to win every time this
is what sports has taught me that I
could give my absolute best and it's not
good enough and that's just the reality
it sucks but it's the reality second
thing is it might be that he's applying
for jobs that require more experience
than he has we see this a lot with young
people my goodness I've I've coached
thousands of people in their 30s and 40s
who make this mistake so what we want to
do here is we want to make sure that
we're applying for something that I know
he has the experience for and now he's
got to win the interview process uh and
and other than that there's not much
advice I can give here I would I would
add one thing go for it okay we have a
digital art student right right am I
missing something no okay so um I'm
going to work on interview skills 100%
I'm going to work on my grooming yeah my
dress my
smile uh my engaging eye contact yeah a
firm handshake a uh the ability to
connect with the other human sometimes
people in the creative community and the
technology Community haven't worked on
those skills that's right sometimes
sometimes they have but sometimes they
haven't uh and they could be excellent
programmers excellent digital uh artists
or whatever he's doing in the gaming
World here um and and have crummy people
skills yep that that's possible possible
but there and he's dejected oh of course
and deflated and he's coming in with his
lips stuck out and his tail dragging
behind him that's right so you got to
get your tail up and be wagging waging
the tail waging the tail there are
seasons where you have to do things like
this but I think there three words that
gets him where he needs to be
relationships relationships
relationships proximity principal 100%
wrote an entire book on that number one
bestseller and it's it's how I started
in my early 30s and broke into the
broadcasting industry took me nine years
to get to this personality role
something I dreamed of so I'm not an
overnight success very few people are
but it is about relationships folks it
is listen that's where you get in the
interview process and you pretty much
just have to do a decent job well your
friend will get you the interview that's
right because they but theyve already
heard good things about you or your
friend's dad will get you out of the
stack your friend's mom get you out of
the stack and then you get the interview
so I uh I was talking to a young man
this week just graduated with his MBA
and he was top of his class he won the
award number one guy in the class
academically and he goes now that I got
my
MBA and he said I'm he's changing jobs
and he said what's your advice and I
said I don't tell anybody right just
tell just you need to tell everybody
that you want a new job and and you got
an NBA that's that you're an awesome guy
and you got an NBA not now that I got my
NBA cuz I got to tell you nobody gives a
crap yeah nobody gives a crap they don't
care you're the number one guy but
nobody cares I'm I'm I'm a real I'm a
real encourager well
no it's really true I I mean it's just
oh my gosh yeah so but I said you know
but you know the good the good news is
that guy was sharp and he already has
two job interviews set up and I said
how'd you get those he goes one of the
guys was was uh in the NBA program with
me works at the company got me in got me
in the job I said see the relationship
got you the interview you'll go hold
your head up look the guy in the eye
firm handshake you'll get the job and
the NBA will just be a little window
dressing to the whole thing it is not
the key to the door baby you're the key
to the door NBA stands for means barely
anything I came up with that the other
day I'm not I'm not crapping on NBA
students that's mean no it's not it just
means that that's what I means barely
anything you nailed it as his mom I
would tell him to get the proximity
principal um I tell you what can we look
this up James and send him one we can
find out who this was I don't we just m
if he's a caller I just give it to him
right now but yeah send him a proximity
principal um and um have him go to King
coleman.com and look at the interview
technique yeah uh we have a free uh
guide there how to win the interview how
to win the interview and it includes
grooming you know it does actually it
does it does I tell guys iron your
stinking clothes or steam them some guys
are a look like you just slept in them
yeah and you come in for work and take a
bath oh my God yeah it's amazing it's
true yeah I'm not saying this kid stinks
I'm not saying that but he could by the
way since the lady led the question with
I'm not a helicopter mom this will blow
your mind Dave that's like when you're
dating a girl and she says I'm not crazy
right you should you should leave with
that it means you're a helicopter mom
100% of the time means she's crazy we're
seeing more and more Jin Z parents show
up to job interviews with their kid it's
absolutely truth what is this it's from
HR data these are no actually physically
showing up showing up with the
kid that let me that's 100% means I'm
not hiring that kid no mommy walks in
you're done we're not going to have a
conversation that happens to Ramsey I'm
going to tell them don't even conduct
the interview
lucif foration of America mommy comes on
the interview yeah we should have a bat
phone for Dave if somebody ever does
that and we call him and he interrupts
whatever he's doing he walks in there
and tells the parent what he really
thinks about that that would be
brilliant on television but this is
happening this is real that's that's
that's that's just you got to let these
kids go I mean you have to let them live
I can't breathe that's unable I knew you
weren't going to like that but that is
absolutely real that is a growing Trend
where parent just cannot allow their kid
to face you know we're picking on this
lady but she's she's just concerned I
don't think she's a helicopter mom but
don't lead with it if you're not that's
that's a hint there too but but
seriously she's worried about it he be
able to get a job and so she's asking a
solid question it's tough it's tough
appreciate I appreciate getting to deal
with it cuz it's it is hard out there
and learning to but I think the most
important thing I've ever learned about
getting a job was from you and that's
the proximity principle yeah I think
that is more more effective oh it is
than any there's no resume technique
there's no guaranteed thing that makes
you stand out that's a bunch of crap and
it's not certainly not a degree it it
it's it's you got to get you got to get
in the interview you got to win the
interview but the first thing is you got
to actually get the interview yeah and
that's the proximity principle you got
to know somebody inside there that'll
open the door for you that's a big deal
huge it is who you know this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host this is the Ramsey show Merry
Christmas America bill is in
Indianapolis hi Bill welcome to the
Ramsey
Show um hi Dave thanks for taking the
call sure what's
up um I want to find out
how bad of an idea it would be to gift
my 18-year-old son my childhood
home okay so you own it free and
clear uh me and my
brother mom your brother wants to give
it to him as well yes my brother uh he
yes he's he's willing to give him his
half um you I'm willing to give him
what's the property worth
uh roughly right now probably a hundred
okay it needs tell me about your son
stuck
in um great kid I mean couldn't ask for
any better kid through school and stuff
like that he has
no ambition he didn't want to go to
college um and I wasn't going to push
him uh you know used to send him to
drink beer for three or four years I go
with that what's he do
so he he got him a job working at a same
Factory where my wife works at mhm
making what kind of
money um he's
1850 1875 something like that right
now so you know what's he GNA do with
his
life well he doesn't know yet so you led
the question how bad of an idea is it
and I'm not trying to read too much into
that but me think makes think it's a bad
idea why do you think it's a bad idea
yeah what's going on well I mean just
just handing the handing an
18-year-old kid a a house um you know
the financial responsibilities it it
needs it it hasn't had anything done to
it since the 80s um it is stuck in the
60s from when it was built um wood
handling uh acoustic tile SE SE I mean
honestly to to make it a a really good
flippable house I mean it needs to be
gutted so so but but he could sell it
today for
100k I I I think I think it would bring
100,000 right now just the way it says
needing to be flipped yes so really the
thing is this 18-year-old kid is making
$18 at the factory and we don't know
what he's going to do with his life
you're handing him
$100,000 yeah basically yes yeah you are
yeah cuz he could sell it right after
you hand it to
him yeah he could that's the I don't
think he would I don't think he would do
my thing was was that you know if it was
it was gifted to me and my brother by my
mom you know she claimed it to us 10
years ago um so we have we have you wer
18 well no no but you know if if we sold
it it would all it would all be you know
cathal gains um every bit of it if give
it to him if it's his for if he holds it
for two years then he could sell it as
his primary residence and and that
capital gains would be gone yeah that's
true you don't have capital gains on it
though you're I mean unless you got did
you get it as an inheritance or did she
give it to you proud to death she just
just just private she mom's still living
but she just she just deed it she deed
it to yeah that well you are right then
you've analyzed that properly then yeah
I wouldn't do it if I were you I'm
trusting you you would yeah I'd give it
to him really yeah but I'm going to put
some terms on it here's my terms okay I
want to hear this okay I want him to
have a plan yes for his life right and
for the renovation of the
property right that's his sign that he
and and the third thing is he promises
never to borrow any
money I I'm yep I I agree with that I
want I want to see a plan for renovation
I want to see a plan for your
life and um and and you sign a letter
that says I promise Dad uncle and Granny
I'm never going to borrow money I'm
going to use this as a way to become
wealthy I'm going to live here I'm going
to renovate it I'm going to sell it for
three or $400,000 in three or four years
after I fixed it up and pay no capital
gains on it meantime I'm going to have a
career and I'm going to go do something
and be
somebody I don't I don't want him 38
years old working I don't want him 38
years old still working
there I want him to go do something with
his life don't you yeah I I do I do too
but you know uh uh hey Bill today's 18
18 year old boys just don't have that
drive yes they do a lot of some do it's
not about this generation it's about the
person in the environment my question is
do you think your son be really honest
do you think your son will honor that
agreement that Dave laid out I like that
agreement do you think your son will
honor it yes I yeah I do okay I'd like
to see him have some more hardship I
don't disagree with Dave's conditions I
love Dave's deal but I'd like to see an
18-year-old have to have to work hard
save for something giving him that is a
big Leap Forward might let him live
there for a year rentree uh with the
promise of giving it to him if he does a
couple of these things I want him to do
something hard yeah let's let's let's
put a little skin in the game yeah but
I'm I'm old like that none of this is
anything I just don't want I want this
to be a blessing and not a curse it's a
curse if he says since I don't have rent
I don't have to work much and I don't
have to work hard and I can sit here in
the old wood paning and drink beer all
weekend and that's worse than having
sent him to school to to drink beer for
three years so that's what you don't
want to do so if you get something where
we put him up on a track and he has an
obligation that he's going to fulfill
for his own goodh then that's good but
may maybe let him sit there a year and
at the end of that year we will deed it
to you if you are doing these three
things uh you're promising not to borrow
money you have a a game plan to do the
renovation and you've already begun some
of the light work on the renovation
while you're there
and uh I want to see some movement in
your career I want you get up off your
little butt and getting gear and if
you're going to do all that we're going
to give you a free house buddy if you're
not then you're going to go be somewhere
else MH I like that might might go for a
year on it and try I want to use it as
leverage to get him moving that's where
I'm at I want gumption I need that's an
old word we don't use a lot but I think
I want to see gumption out of the kid
and I think the dad is worried about
that yeah he he's just worried yeah the
downside is is if you you know it's the
a miniature version of a trust fund baby
not quite but I mean I agree that's why
I wouldn't give it to him yet yeah I
think I think put some stipulation on
maybe do a delayed handoff that kind of
thing that I like the idea of where it
could take him mathematically if he
plays through and what you're saying
bill is very true he holds it two years
he sells it he's going to have all that
money taxfree it's a taxfree up to
250,000 gain and it'll probably be a
full gain uh for a single if he's
married by then you know it would be uh
500,000 that he can make on that house
and have no taxes so yeah Fix It Up live
there till he's 25 he's married and he
makes some serious bank and by then his
career is taken off because he's got a
whole game plan he's got he's got up and
got moving and yeah I like that that
that kind of thing if he's just going to
sit on his butt and work as little as he
can work I'm going to work I'm going to
get there late leave early and not do
much while I'm there and uh look I'm
working for the weekend I'm Huey news
right huie Lewis in the news right
that's right you know and it's just yeah
if that's you then I'm not supporting
that activity because it's not a
blessing that's not going to give him
the life he wants cuz I love him that
yeah that kind of thing that's what I'm
looking for Bill but it's a great
discussion and what a generosity move on
your brother's part wow on your part but
on your brother's part for sure yeah
that's very kind to him I mean that's
50,000 bucks he's handing his nephew
that's I was sitting there thinking well
you and your brother could fix that
sucker up and flip it and then give the
young man some investment I get it but
I'll pay taxes if I got a bunch of
profit yeah that's true you you could go
there I it's interesting it's a great
mama's house mama's still alive so you
some interesting she'd rather have her
grand baby in there well that's true but
um but you know what you've nailed it I
I'm worried about him getting adult camp
you know he's working at the factory
where mama works and then he's got this
free place and party hardy and all that
garbage and it's not real world and I
think that's me you and I don't know
anybody that would have done something
like that at 18 other than the two
people sitting here but yeah we're the
only guys that know anybody like that
but yeah yeah yeah I would have messed
that deal up I'm afraid I would have as
well I promise you I would have messed
that
up this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
our scripture of the day Isaiah 2924
those who are confused will gain
understanding and those who Grumble will
accept
instruction Jordan Peterson says in
order to be able to think you have to
risk being
[Music]
offensive well Jordan you got it down
man yes you got that one dialed in buddy
proud of you you scored yes so fun stuff
yeah I uh went to our friends at Daily
wire um here here in Nashville uh that
have Jordan and
um Ben shapir and others on their team
and of course Jordan has spoken for us
at a thing I've been on Ben's show I've
known Ben a long time and Sharon and I
went to the Christmas party the other
night oh I didn't know this and uh they
were kind enough to invite us and uh so
we went down hung out with them and got
to talk to Ben a little bit I hadn't
talked to him since all this stuff has
gone down in Israel and uh man it's
pretty Rowdy around their place the U
imagine the death threats that he is
getting right now uh uh with the anti
anti-Semitism that is risen is just nuts
um he um he he's just pretty nonchalant
about having 24 hour a day Security in
his home yeah
W only security I've got the Second
Amendment laying by my bed but but not
as many I mean people are mad at me and
hate me but nothing like those guys
those guys man they get crap wow it's
amazing but they were having a nice
Christmas party it was nice of them to
that's fun Ben Ben is a really really
genuinely nice nice guy great great
folks all right I'll name drop a little
Max is in Toronto Canada hey Max what's
up hi okay hey Max how are you hey doing
well sir great to speak with you again
don't remember but two years ago we
spoke my parents were going through a
messy divorce and you helped me get in
touch with a pastor who really blessed
my life so I wanted to thank you with
that first very cool very cool how can
we help today
sure yeah reason for the call today is I
wanted to I guess just give you the
question then get the background
information wondering if I should quit
my job to pursue a full-time career as
an entrepreneur in the social media
space okay what kind of
space yeah so kind of my idea right now
would be to do pomy on YouTube as well
as longer form podcast
content kind of what's your content what
what are you offering on social media
what is the career area you're in what's
your what's what are you what are you
helping people with
yeah your your phone's breaking up try
one more
time it would be for self-improvement
for young men kind of in
Fitness you broke up again I think you
said Fitness did you say
Fitness yeah okay all right so what do
you do now and what do you make in that
job I think we're having all kinds of
problems with Max on the connection
there Max you there
can you hear case no no we can't hear
you we'll put you on hold see if they
can get you fixed up we'll come back to
you uh Cade Cadron is uh Cadron kadron
is up and in Seattle Hi kadron how are
you hi I'm well thanks so much for
taking my call sure how can I
help so um my husband and I are recently
married in our 40s we each own our own
home uh he has sold his we are now
living in my smaller home he has a a
stepdaughter um who we have about 50% of
the time and so we need to um buy a
house that is closer to her school
district um and we also just need a
little bit more space so our my question
is um we have a couple of options option
one is for us to keep this current home
we're in uh keep it as a rental uh and
buy a house up in near this other school
district I assume the home that you're
in has a morgage and your new home will
have a mortgage correct okay I would not
do that then okay yeah you're becoming a
landlord by default not by
plan you weren't if you were living over
in that other property and had a
mortgage you wouldn't look up and go I'm
going to go buy a rental over there in
that other neighborhood with a
Deb this is by default it's not by
plan you're going to end up you you need
to use every bit of equity you have and
put it on that other house to have as
little debt over there as you can have
and get that other house paid off when
your personal residence is paid off save
up and buy a rental with cash later on
if you can when you can but until then
right now what you all need is to get a
paid for home to live in okay that make
any sense that's the direction we always
take
people yeah and that makes perfect sense
I'm just wondering our 10e plan is that
in 10 years we would move back to this
area where we currently live um because
this is Ultimate where where we would
want to be after my stepdaughter
graduated from high school so even if
that was our plan would you still give
that same advice yes and I'll give you
another reason now then okay on top of
that um I own a home that we lived in
for 13 years and I raised our children
in and then we built a home about the
time they all left that home has been
sold we're in a third home since then um
but we've kept the other property as a
rental it was all paid for all along it
is an emot and I know this I've known
this for a grew up in the real estate
business I've been warned about this
since I was 18 years old this is
returning to a property you used to live
in after tenants have lived in it is
emotionally
rough they didn't do what they didn't
it's they didn't take care of your old
your old baby you know and moving back
into it is really hard because it
shrinks after you
leave
it's like it's like when you go back to
your Elementary School like what they do
with those rooms they were huge when I
was a kid and they're tiny how did we
even get in the door in these little
bitty rooms and and you know we I went
back to one of the houses we lived in we
first got married and the people were
kind enough to let us go in I found the
shower I used to take I don't know how I
got in the thing it was so small yeah it
just shrunk considerably and I I
couldn't have gotten any bigger that's
not possible but no it's a emotional you
will have 10 years worth of renters that
you will have to rehab and clean out and
you'd be better off just to buy a
different house and um and that plan
might not take place also it might you
might not be moving back there you got a
lot of fresh change in your life right
now and to anticipate what's going to
happen 10 years from now in light of
this all this fresh change is very
difficult I would just make my life
simple clean sell it let's go take care
of this teenager get her in the right
School raise her when she's gone then
we'll re-evaluate where we want to live
we might come back there we might not
and you're not tied to it in any way by
decisions you made a decade before I
just dump that money over into that
other house get that other house paid
for build you a big old pile of cash so
you got options from 10 years that are
completely unlimited i' put yourself in
that position it is so weird you ever
done that gone back to a house you used
to live in yeah I went back to my
boyhood home um about 10 years ago we
went back where my dad had started in
pastor church for a long time we moved
away when I was 12 went back so excited
to show my family and it looked like a
dollhouse mhm and I and my vision was I
remember playing in this room and I
thought it was massive and I looked at
it and it was like a cubby so yeah for
my boyhood home it blew my mind how
small it was yeah the house I grew up in
was an incredible home and it was it was
1,4 sare F feet yeah that's about what
mine was my dad said it was just a
little bit over 1,000 sareet Hardwood FL
bath and a half yeah three three
bedrooms bath and a half and um my my
parents bought it in 1963 yeah um and uh
for
$2,575 MH and uh uh the we did not I
thought I didn't know living rooms all
had Furniture cuz ours didn't have
furniture I when my when we made enough
money several years later to buy living
room furniture and prior to that that
room sat empty like for 5 years wow or
more I mean I was a little kid when we
got living room furniture but I was a
little kid with and we played in that
living room it was like our own little
gym yeah of course because it was empty
and uh but they they you know finally
got living room furniture and put in
there and oh my gosh did your mom put
plastic on it no they that was one of
their things they wanted they said if
you you should live in the living room I
agree it should not be a museum love
that philosophy it should not be a
museum they they love the idea that when
great rooms came out that did away with
the formal living room oh yeah and it
was just one big family room yeah big
great rooms remember when great rooms
came in in the 70s wow yeah so that that
whole thing but yeah it's interesting
it's an interesting um set of emotions
you I like what you said the advice is
so great because you said options that
is the operating word give yourself
options for old pile of money and
options and simplicity will add to your
pile of money it's good stuff that puts
us hour the Ramsey Show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jes
[Music]
[Applause]
Jesus